These days, major movie studios mark their
spots on the release schedule years ahead
of time, and it seems like audiences have
to wait forever once a film is announced.
But before you know it, we'll all be buying
our tickets for summer 2018's hottest big
screen blockbusters.
From superhero sequels to explosive crime
thrillers to mind-bending horror flicks, it
looks like there's a whole lineup of films
that are well worth the wait.
Among the dozens of promising projects slated
for release, here are some of the movies that
are going to hit big.
Hereditary
According to critics, Hereditary isn't your
run-of-the-mill fright flick, it's a movie
that's going to leave you shaken to your very
core.
Starring Toni Collette, Hereditary tells the
story of a family dealing with grief after
the passing of a grandmother.
Unfortunately, Grandma might not be gone,
and she might not be so friendly.
The AV Club described the film as "pure emotional
terrorism," and it's got an ending that Daily
Dead compared to movies like Carrie and The
Witch.
In other words, prepare yourself for some
cinematic trauma.
Ocean's Eight
Using the same basic premise of Ocean's Eleven,
a group of quirky cons pull off an incredibly
elaborate heist, Ocean's Eight has done a
gender swap.
A movie like this relies on the likability
of its cast, similar to the George Clooney
version, Ocean's Eight has assembled one of
the very best teams in recent memory.
With an actor lineup this awesome, it's seems
likely that Ocean's Eight will totally be
able to hold its own against Steven Soderbergh's
classic.
"Do we have to steal stuff?"
"Yes."
Incredibles 2
14 years after the release of The Incredibles,
our crime-fighting family is ready to save
the world yet again, and Incredibles 2 is
going to pick up right where the old one left
off.
As for the plot, the exact details are hard
to find, but we know Craig T. Nelson's Mr.
Incredible will be staying at home, watching
after his superpowered baby, while Holly Hunter's
Elastigirl goes on an adventure and stretches
her superpowers to new limits.
Bob Odenkirk and Catherine Keener have also
joined the cast, and while we don't know who
they're playing yet, there's a good chance
they might be some sort of dastardly duo.
"Bye Sweetie…"
"I'll watch the kids, no problem."
Jurassic World: Fallen Kingdom
When Jurassic World roared into theaters in
2015, it quickly became the fourth highest-grossing
film of all time, raking in nearly $1.7 billion
dollars.
Now, with Jurassic World: Fallen Kingdom,
not only will we get to see raptors run amok,
but we'll also watch an abandoned theme park
get blown to smithereens.
Directed by J.A. Bayona, this blockbuster
promises to be an over-the-top spectacle,
complete with the return of Jeff Goldblum's
Ian Malcolm.
It's pretty safe to say Fallen Kingdom won't
go extinct at the box office.
"Life finds a way."
Sicario: Day of the Soldado
You wouldn't necessarily think a movie like
Sicario needs a sequel, but rest assured,
Sicario: Day of the Soldado is in good hands.
Sicario scribe Taylor Sheridan, the genius
behind Hell or High Water and Wind River,
wrote the screenplay, resulting in what's
bound to be an incredible thriller.
According to The Independent, director Stefano
Sollima promises a more cinematic film than
the first, featuring, quote, "an incredible
amount of huge action sequences."
We're also going to get a film that's far
darker than the first, with returning star
Josh Brolin describing the story as "severe,"
and Sheridan telling IndieWire that
"[Soldado] makes the first one look like a
comedy."
The First Purge
The Purge franchise has been picking off victims
and making political points since 2013, but
now, with The First Purge, we'll get an answer
as to how this night of bloodshed all started.
Directed by newcomer Gerard McMurray and written
by franchise mastermind James DeMonaco, the
newest film will take place before the Ethan
Hawke original.
DeMonaco told Entertainment Weekly that the
cast will be 90 percent black, adding to the
film's socio-political message.
Naturally, the film is set to hit theaters
on July 4th, when fireworks will light the
sky and blood will flow in the streets.
Ant-Man and the Wasp
Audiences are in for a marvelous time when
Ant-Man and the Wasp arrives on July 6th.
With Peyton Reed returning to direct, both
Paul Rudd and Evangeline Lilly will be suiting
up as the titular heroes.
Apparently, the pair will attempt to rescue
Michelle Pfeiffer's Janet van Dyne from her
decades-long adventure lost in the quantum
realm.
Lilly told Vanity Fair,
"If we do succeed in Ant-Man and the Wasp,
then that does open a whole entire new multi-verse
to enter into and play around in."
In other words, things are going to get super
weird after Infinity War.
The Equalizer 2
Ready to see a super assassin and hardware
expert dispose of some gangsters with gardening
tools?
Your dreams may very well come true on August
3rd, when Denzel Washington returns for The
Equalizer 2.
Re-teaming with director Antoine Fuqua, Washington
is making history here, starring in his very
first sequel.
There aren't a lot of plot details out there,
but come on, we're going to see Denzel destroy
a bunch of bad guys in incredibly creative
ways.
What more do you need to know?
Mission Impossible: Fallout
Tom Cruise's Ethan Hunt is at it again.
"Oh, you know, same old Ethan."
Director Christopher McQuarrie returns to
helm a sixth installment to the covert op
action-adventure series.
McQuarrie has promised that we will, "[get]
to know who Ethan is in this movie," and that
our action hero will actually go on an emotional
journey, maybe that's why Michelle Monaghan
is returning as Ethan's old flame.
In addition to a killer cast, we're super
psyched to see the crazy stunts Cruise and
McQuarrie have cooked up.
Cruise trained for a year to prepare for some
truly insane action sequences, and we can't
wait until July 27th to see how the superstar
puts his life on the line this time.
The Meg
Cue the creepy music, because The Meg is an
ancient shark that's tormenting deep sea fishermen
in this adaptation of bestseller Meg: A Novel
of Deep Terror.
The film features Jason Statham as a rescue
diver who must help a stranded submarine and
its crew escape the teeth of the prehistoric
beast.
Shark movies automatically earn creeping dread
just by their nature, but this flick looks
to take us into the depths of our fears, it's
literally dropping the distressed crew into
the deepest parts of the Pacific Ocean, so
we're in for an action-packed treat.
Captive State
John Goodman is revisiting the sci-fi genre
with Captive State, an alien invasion thriller
from Rupert Wyatt, the director who gave us
Rise of the Planet of the Apes.
According to the official plot description,
the film is set in Chicago "nearly a decade
after an occupation by an extra-terrestrial
force."
Captive State will focus on "the lives on
both sides of the conflict, the collaborators
and dissidents," and we can't wait for this
science fiction flick to invade movie theaters
on August 17th.
White Boy Rick
At only 14 years old, a Caucasian teenager
from Detroit named Rick Wershe Jr. was recruited
as a snitch by the FBI.
He went on to help the feds arrest some dangerous
drug lords, before becoming a big-time dealer
himself.
A story this wild was just begging for someone
to make it into a movie, and fortunately,
White Boy Rick is set to hit theaters on August
17th.
As real-life Ricky's story recently took a
strange turn, it'll be interesting to see
how these events will affect the film.
White Boy Rick promises to be one of the craziest
true crime stories of the year.
Mandy
It seems like Nicolas Cage's entire career
was leading to Mandy.
All the freaky faces, all the onscreen breakdowns,
all the awesome Nicolas Cage moments were
building up to this.
"Oh, yeah!
You put your right foot in.
You take your right foot out.
You do the hokey-pokey and you f---ing work
it all out."
The result is a big bloody of explosion of
LSD weirdness and battle axe action mixed
with rage, pain, and a lot of vodka.
Mandy finds Cage playing a man who embarks
on a revenge mission in a film that, according
to The Verge,
"...combines the most absurd aesthetic excesses
of '70s and '80s horror films with the most
absurd thespian excesses of Nicolas Cage."
...which obviously makes Mandy sound like
one of the greatest movies ever made.
The Nun
The Conjuring series is quickly making its
case that horror movie franchises can also
become extended universes.
Following in the success of the franchise's
first spinoff, Annabelle, producers have given
the Demon Nun from The Conjuring 2 her own
film, titled simply The Nun.
The plot, which may be a prequel to The Conjuring
2, involves a priest who is called in to investigate
a nun's passing in Rome.
If there's anything we've learned about demonic
presences in Hollywood history, it's that
Italy tends to provide quite a creepy backdrop.
This'll definitely be one to watch.
(listening to metal for the first time)
Robin Hood
We've had Errol Flynn, Kevin Costner, and
an animated fox.
Now it looks like Taron Egerton will don Robin
Hood's trademark green tights.
Robin Hood is going to be like a medieval
version of Batman Begins, showing us how Robin
of Locksley became Great Britain's most famous
bandit.
According to Deadline, the movie will take
place after Robin returns home from the Crusades
only to find that Sherwood Forest is now "rife
with corruption and evil."
Jamie Foxx, who's playing Little John, says
the movie, quote, "looks like you're watching
Zero Dark Thirty."
Taking Robin Hood in a dark direction is certainly
an interesting choice, and with the winning
combo of Egerton and Foxx, the upcoming action
flick could be one of 2018's most exciting
movies.
The House with a Clock in its Walls
Eli Roth isn't really known for his kid-friendly
films, but he's looking to change things up
with The House with a Clock in its Walls.
Based on the classic children's book, this
Gothic fright flick tells the story of a 10-year-old
boy who's sent to live in a quiet Michigan
town with his uncle… who turns out to be
a warlock.
There's also a witch next door, plus an apocalyptic
clock, hidden in the walls, of course, and
things get especially tricky when our hero
resurrects an evil being.
This spooky movie is set to scare kids on
September 21st.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!